สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วัน
อาทิตย์แล้วกันเนาะวันอาทิตย์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
เมษายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ 2013
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันเสาร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 22
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
เมษายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้
วันจันทร์
ที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 24
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนเมษายน
ค่ะปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา
5 ทุ่ม
10 นาที 5 ทุ่ม
10 นาทีค่ะ
ทำไมเราสองคนไปนอนล่ะคะครูฟ้าทำไมครูหญิง
ยังไม่นอน 5 ทุ่มแล้วนะผู้หญิงต้องนอนได้
แล้ว
ครูหญิงคะ
ทำไมครูหญิงยังไม่นอนก็เพราะว่า
พี่เพราะว่าอะไรคะ
ยังไม่นอน
ถูกต้องไม่ใช่ก็เพราะว่าครูหญิงอยู่ที่
ประเทศไทยยังไงล่ะคะแล้วเดือนนี้คือช่อง
แคบอะไรคะเนี่ย
อะไรคะครูฟ้า
ผู้หญิงอยู่ประเทศไทยผู้หญิงยังไม่นอน
เพราะว่าครูหญิงอยู่ประเทศไทยประเทศไทย
นอนไม่ได้หรอคะ
ไม่ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่า 5 ทุ่มเนี่ยมันเป็น
เวลาที่ออสเตรเลียค่ะครูฟ้าที่ประเทศไทย
เนี่ยตอนนี้ 2 ทุ่ม 10 นาทีค่ะไม่ใช่ 5
ทุ่มครูหญิงก็เลยยังไม่นอนไง
กินข้าวแล้วค่ะแต่ว่ากินข้าวไปตอน
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยกินข้าวไปตอนประมาณอุ้ย
5 โมงเย็นกินข้าวไปตอน 5 โมงเย็นเนี่ย
ตอนนี้ก็ 2 ทุ่มแล้วเดี๋ยวทำงานอัดวีดีโอ
กับครูฟ้าเสร็จก็น่าจะประมาณ
21:30 น
ผู้หญิงคิดว่าผู้หญิงต้องหิวอีกแน่ๆเลย
ค่ะอัดวีดีโอกับครูฟ้าเสร็จเนี่ยครูหญิง
คิดว่าผีจะต้องเดิน
ต๊อกแต๊กต๊อกแต๊กต๊อกแต๊กแล้วก็ไปเปิดตู้
เย็นดู
ตู้เย็น
นี่คือตู้เย็นของผู้หญิงหรอ
ครูหญิงเลยนะตู้เย็นครูหญิงก็มี 2 ประตู
นะประตูที่ 1 แล้วก็ประตูที่ 2 ที่บ้าน
ครูฟ้าที่ออสเตรเลียเนี่ยมีตู้เย็นหรือ
เปล่าคะ
ไม่ต้องใช้ตู้เย็นหรอกค่ะเพราะว่าหนาวมาก
มันไม่เหมือนกันค่ะเราหนาวกับอาหารเนี่ย
เหมือนกันค่ะครูฟ้า
ที่บ้านครูฟ้าที่ออสเตรเลียมีตู้เย็นกี่
เครื่องคะ
มีตู้เย็น
1 สิคะ
อ๋อมี 1 หรอเอาก็ไม่รู้ไงบ้านคู่ฟ้าที่
พัทยามีตู้เย็นเยอะมากนะคุณผู้หญิงทำได้
ที่พัทยานี่ก็ยังเยอะมาก
ประเทศไทยร้อนเกี่ยวอะไรกับตู้เย็นคะ
บอกว่าออสเตรเลียหนาวไงไม่มีตู้เย็นก็ได้
ครูก็สามารถวางน้ำไว้
แล้วน้ำก็เย็น
เห็นไหม
ได้ค่ะแต่ว่าตู้เย็นเนี่ยนะคะมีหรือไม่มี
ตู้เย็นมันก็ไม่ทำให้มันคืออะไรคะคุณหญิง
ใจเย็นๆค่ะมันก็ไม่เท่ากับว่าเวลาที่เรา
เปิดตู้เย็นแล้วเนี่ย
ข้างในตู้เย็นเราเนี่ยมีอะไรบ้างโอ้โหนี่
ถ้าเป็นอันนี้ไม่ใช่ตู้เย็นที่บ้านครู
หญิงแน่นอนค่ะไม่ใช่ค่ะ
เปิดมาปุ๊บโอ้โหมีผลไม้
มีผักมีเนื้อสัตว์มีไข่มีไข่มีของมีอาหาร
เต็มตู้เย็นอย่างนี้
ไม่ใช่ของคุณหญิงแน่นอนค่ะ
ไม่ใช่หรอกมันไม่ใช่ของพวกฟ้าด้วยนะคะ
มันจะเป็นไปได้ยังไง
ที่มีผัก
ผักเยอะมากเห็นไหม
เนี่ย
2 ชั้นเลยนะ
มีอาหารด้วยคือตู้เย็นที่บ้านครูหญิง
เนี่ยนะคะ
เปิดมาเนี่ย
ไม่ค่อยมีอะไรเลยค่ะเปิดมาในตู้เย็นเนี่ย
เปิดมาแล้วก็คิดถ้าหิวใช่ไหมคะหิวแล้ว
เนี่ย
ถ้าเป็นตู้เย็นแบบนี้เปิดมาปุ๊บโอ้โหมี
แทรก
มีแซนด์วิชมีสตอเบอรี่มีผลไม้
อันนี้ก็โอเคแต่ถ้าเป็นตู้เย็นบ้านครู
หญิงเนี่ย
เปิดมาแล้วก็หา
ไม่มีอะไร
ผู้หญิงต้องหยิบโทรศัพท์มาแล้วก็เปิด
แอปพลิเคชั่น Grab ดีกว่าค่ะน่าจะมีอาหาร
ให้กินมากกว่า
ตู้เย็นที่บ้านครูฟ้าที่ออสเตรเลียเนี่ย
เปิดมาเป็นแบบในรูปนี้ไหมคะมีของเต็มตู้
เย็นเลยใช่ค่ะ
แต่จะมีอาหารเยอะไม่ได้มีผักเยอะขนาดนี้
นะคะ
แต่ว่าไม่กินผัก
ก็มีแหละผักจะอยู่ข้างล่างของครูฟ้าตู้
เย็นที่ออสเตรเลียเนี่ยนะคะข้างล่างจะ
เป็น Freeze
เหมือนกันเนาะ
ถ้าตู้เย็นที่ไทยเนี่ยฟรีซจะอยู่ที่นี่
ค่ะ
ก็จะมีของในตู้เย็นใช่ไหมคะก็มีผักมี
ผลไม้มีอะไรอย่างนี้แหละก็มันก็แล้วแต่
ว่าบ้านไหนเนี่ยจะมีอะไร
ใช่ไหมมีก็คือเราชอบกินอะไรก็จะมีของนั้น
น่ะอยู่ในตู้เย็นแต่ว่าวันนี้เราไม่ได้มา
คุยกันว่าในตู้เย็นบ้านครูฟ้าตู้เย็นบ้าน
ครูหญิงเนี่ยมีอะไรบ้างแต่เราจะมาคุยกัน
ว่าในตู้เย็นเนี่ยที่บ้านของเราเนี่ยนะคะ
มันจะมีอะไรที่เขาเรียกอะไรนะมันจะมีติด
ตู้เย็นตลอดเวลาคือไม่ว่าเราจะเปิดตู้
เย็นเวลาไหนเปิดตู้เย็นวันไหนวันจันทร์
วันอังคารวันพุธเราไม่ได้ไปช้อปปิ้งนานๆ
หรือว่าเปิดตู้เย็นมาไม่มีอาหารแต่ว่ามัน
ต้องมีอันนี้ติดอยู่ในตู้เย็นตลอดเวลา
ค่ะซึ่งจริงๆนะ
นักเรียนด้วยก็คือไข่ค่ะ
อันนี้คือไข่หรอคะ
อยู่ออสเตรเลีย 1 เดือนนี่กินภาษาอังกฤษ
เข้าไปหรอคะ
ตู้เย็น
เครื่อง
เปิดมาเนี่ยคิดว่าทั้ง 5 เครื่องเนี่ย
ทั้งตู้เย็น 5 ตู้ก็ได้ 5 เครื่องก็ได้
เนี่ยนะคะต้องมีไข่ทุกตู้มันเป็นของที่
ต้องมีติดตู้เย็นเอาไว้อ่ะค่ะไข่เนี่ยเรา
วันไหนสมมุติภูฟ้ากับครูหญิงเนี่ยดู
ซีรีส์เสร็จประมาณซักตี 1
แล้วก็มาหยิบไข่แล้วก็กิน
ขอโทษค่ะ
มันกินไม่ได้ไหมเออ
เราหิวเราก็มาเปิดตู้เย็นอาจจะไม่มีผัก
ไม่มีไม่มีไม่มีไม่มีไม่มีไม่มีไม่มีหมด
เพราะว่ายังไม่ได้ไป Supermarket แต่ต้อง
มีไข่อยู่แน่ๆต้องมีไข่ติดตู้เย็นเอาไว้
ใช่ค่ะนั่นแหละ
ตู้เย็นตู้เย็นที่บ้านครูฟ้าที่ไม่ใช่ที่
พัทยาที่ออสเตรเลียเนี่ยมีไข่ติดตู้เย็น
เอาไว้ไหมคะมีค่ะ
เพราะว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะคะชอบกินไข่
เจียวไข่ไว้
[เพลง]
ตู้เย็นที่บ้านครูหญิงเนี่ยที่
คอนโดมิเนียมเนี่ยนะคะเปิดมาปุ๊บเนี่ยแบบ
เปิดมานะนักเรียนสมมุติเปิดแล้วเนี่ย
ฉันฉันเนี่ยไม่มีไม่มีแต่ตรงนี้มีใครๆๆๆๆ
ต้องมีไข่ค่ะถ้าคุณหญิงเห็นว่าตู้เย็นที่
บ้านครูหญิงเนี่ยไผ่เนี่ยใกล้จะหมดแล้ว
เหลืออยู่ 1  2  3  4  4 ฟองผู้หญิงต้อง
ไป Supermarket แล้วต้องซื้อมาเก็บเอาไว้
แล้วต้องมีไข่เนี่ยติดตู้เย็นเอาไว้แล้ว
ใช่ค่ะคุณหญิงก็ชอบกินไข่มันเป็นอะไรที่
เราทำง่ายๆนะคะนักเรียนเราก็แค่มีกระทะ
ใช่ไหมคะกระทะไฟฟ้าแล้วก็ใส่น้ำแล้วก็เอา
ไข่ใส่ลงไปแล้วก็ต้มต้มๆๆแล้วก็รอต้มซัก 7
นาทีเราก็กินได้แล้วค่ะ
มีไข่ติดตู้เย็นเอาไว้ขิงคิดว่าทุกบ้านก็
ต้องมีเหมือนกันแล้วคือฟ้าคิดว่าที่บ้าน
คนไทยเนี่ยจะมีอะไรที่เราต้องมีติดตู้
เย็นเอาไว้ตลอดเวลา
นอกจากไข่
ครูฝ้าย
อะไรคะ
ใช่ป่ะ
ทำไมถึงมีพริกติดตู้เย็นน่ะบ้านกูยังไม่
มีนะ
บ้านคนที่เป็นบ้านทำกับข้าวที่ไม่ใช่
คอนโดผู้หญิงต้องมีพริกนะ
คะ
ผู้หญิงนะ
เพราะว่าคนไทยชอบกินพริกใช่ไหม
ใช่อาหารไทยก็จะใส่พริกไง
ก็ต้องมีพริกนะคะในตู้เย็นบ้านคนไทยเป็น
เพราะคิดว่าจะมีพริกนั่นแหละในตู้เย็น
ชัวร์
ต้องมีติดตู้เย็นเอาไว้เลยตู้เย็นเลย
ผู้หญิงคิดว่ามีอีกอย่างหนึ่ง
อะไรคะ
เอออันนี้ไม่รู้มีทุกบ้านหรือเปล่าเนาะ
แต่ถ้าแบบว่าเป็น
บ้านที่มีลูกอ่ะน่าจะมีนะนั่นก็คือนมค่ะ
ครูฟ้า
คือดูนักเรียนผู้หญิงว่าอย่างนี้แล้วมัน
เป็นนมไหม
ให้มันจะเข้าใจไหม
เขียนขนาดนี้นักเรียนก็ต้องเข้าใจแหละ
นมไงเวลาที่อะไรคะครูฟ้าครูฟ้าจะวาดให้
คุณหญิงใช่ไหม
เก่งมากค่ะทำไมไม่วาดตั้งแต่แรกนะคะให้
ผู้หญิงวาดอยู่ได้
นม
ผู้หญิงคิดว่านมก็ต้องมีติดบ้านไว้ไหมติด
ต้องมีติดตู้เย็นเอาไว้ไหมยิ่งคนทำอาหาร
ไม่รู้นะบ้านคุณหญิงเนี่ยบางครั้งผู้หญิง
แบบทำแบบ
นี้ค่ะบางคนไทยไม่ใช่หรอ
เราทะเลาะกันแล้ว
โอเคมันไม่มีนม
นมไม่มีงั้นสิคิดว่าอันนี้มีแน่นอนครูฟ้า
อันไหนคะ
บ้านเรือนไทยต้องมี
นั่นก็คือ
นี่ไงกำลังวาดอยู่
น้ำเปล่า
คุณคิดว่าดีไหม
พอนมครูฟ้าบอกว่าไม่มีโอเคน้ำเปล่าพี่คิด
ว่าบ้านคนไทยทุกคนต้องมีน้ำเปล่าในตู้
เย็นต้องมีติดตู้เย็นไว้เลยค่ะไม่ใช่
เพราะว่าเราอะไรนะคะนักเรียนแต่เป็นเพราะ
ว่าประเทศไทยมันร้อนค่ะประเทศไทยเนี่ยดวง
อาทิตย์เนี่ยใหญ่มากมันร้อนเราจะต้องดื่ม
น้ำเย็นค่ะใช่ค่ะแน่นอนแน่นอนชัวร์ 99.99%
คิดว่ามีอะไรอีก
นะคะ
[เพลง]
นั่นก็คือ
วาดไปแล้ว
อะไรคะ
คือคนอร์เป็นก้อนสำหรับเอาไปต้มซุปอ่ะค่ะ
ครูหญิงเนี่ยทำอาหารแบบนานๆ 1 ครั้งแต่
ตู้เย็นบ้านครูหญิงที่คอนโดเนี่ยก็มีที่
บ้านที่ชลบุรีเนี่ย
ก็มีคนอร์นะอันนี้คือกล่องมันใช่ไหม
เดี๋ยวผู้หญิง
ให้นักเรียนดู
ที่แบบว่า
แบบที่ครูฟ้าวาดอ่ะที่เขาแบบ
ที่เขาแกะออกมาแล้วอ่ะมันไม่มีอ่ะครูฟ้า
อะไร
[เพลง]
ไม่มีหรอนี่ๆๆๆๆๆ
นี่ๆๆอันนี้เป็นกล่องเขาใช่ไหมคะนักเรียน
แล้วก็เวลาที่แกะออกมาแล้วมันจะเป็นแบบ
เนี้ยค่ะแล้วถ้าเราจะต้มซุปใช่ไหมก็เอา
น้ำเนี่ยต้มต้มใช่ไหมต้มไฟแล้วก็เอาคะใส่
ลงไปต้มซุปได้แล้วก็อร่อยเลยนะคะไม่ต้อง
ใส่อะไรแล้วใส่นอนอย่างเดียว
ด้านคนไทยต้องมีคุณคิดว่ามีอีกอย่างนึง
ค่ะที่บ้านคนไทยเนี่ยทุกคนจะต้องมีอาจจะ
ไม่ได้เรียกว่ามีติดตู้เย็นน่ะแต่ตู้เย็น
น่ะทุกบ้านน่าจะมีคืออะไรคือ
ให้พูดฟ้าคิดว่าอร่อย
มะนาว
ไม่ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงถูกต้องแล้ว
มันก็จะมีอันนี้ด้วย
นักเรียนแต่มันไม่ใช่มะนาวที่เป็นมะนาว
แบบ
1 ลูกนะ
ไม่นะมันหั่นต้องเป็นมะนาวครึ่งซีกมะนาว
อันนี้เป็นมะนาว 1 ลูกใช่ไหมคะนักเรียน 1
ลูกเนาะแล้วเนี่ย
ทำอาหารแล้วอีกครึ่งนึงเนี่ย
ไม่ได้เอาไปทำไงใช้ไม่หมด
ก็เลยข้างนอก
ตั้งไว้ข้างนอกเนี่ยไม่ได้ก็ใส่ตัวกินเอา
ไว้แล้วก็ที่ครูฟ้าวาดเนี่ยก็คือหันไปอีก
ครึ่งนึงเป็นอีกซีกนึงเลยเนาะ
นี่ๆๆบ้านครูฟ้าเขามีแบบนี้เลยค่ะ
นักเรียนนักเรียนลองเปิดสิมันจะอยู่จนแบบ
ว่าหนึ่งวันสองวันสามวันสี่วันเนี่ยอยู่
จน
ดาวคะนองแล้วก็มะนาวเน่า
แล้วก็เนี่ยค่ะพวกซอสต่างๆ
ซอสพริกอะไรเนี่ยกินไม่หมดมีอยู่ในตู้
เย็นคนไทยใช่แล้วค่ะ
ว่าเป็นของที่จะมีติดตู้เย็นคนไทยนะส่วน
ใหญ่นะคะแล้ว
ประเทศนักเรียนหรือว่าบ้านนักเรียนนะคะ
ที่ตู้เย็นเนี่ยจะต้องมีอะไรติดตู้เย็น
ไว้ตลอดเวลาคิดว่าของนักเรียนมีนมแน่นอน
ก็เลยรู้สึกแบบของไทยก็อร่อยนะแต่อยู่ไทย
ไม่กิน
มันอร่อยนะ
นั่นแหละค่ะมีอะไรบ้างติดตู้เย็น comment
บอกเราได้นะคะส่วนวีดีโอนี้นะคะไปรูปนี้
เหมือนไม่สวยเหมือนกันเนาะผู้หญิงกับครู
ฟ้าไปก่อนแล้วเจอกันใหม่วีดีโอหน้าค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะ